hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast extraction and the
labeling of cannabis products presented
by Jehan Marku PhD chief scientific
officer and she auditor for Americans
for safe access and the patient-focused
certification program I am Judy O'Rourke
of laberd's and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
ward at the bottom center of your screen
or use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Marku I will now turn the presentation
over to him hello we're gonna be
discussing extraction of cannabis
products and the labels of these
products today of this webinar the
topics we're going to discuss is
research on comparing extraction methods
and solvents we're gonna discuss the
issue of pesticides and products as well
as some studies that we've published on
the label accuracy of different products
when it comes to extraction we generally
look for trichomes all
plants a lot of plants most plants make
trichomes
and we have to wonder why they're there
which is a great question that no one in
the audience asked and they're not
really there for our pleasure they're
there for reproduction and defense and
they come in three different types and
this is important because when we talk
about cannabis products the essential
oil the the cannabinoids that is put
into products that is formulated is
coming from try comes from very
particular parts of the plant and so
they come in three flavors there's long
multi-cellular stocked ones like you can
see by the letter e on the far
right-hand side but there's also short
ones or ones that have no stock but have
multicellular heads and this figure here
on this is from our monograph on
cannabis inflorescence which is cited in
a lot of state laws of standards for
taxonomic identification and identity
analysis and so the reason it's
important to know about try comes as if
you're just using your basic scientific
instrument the microscope for example
you can look and identify glandular
versus non glandular trichomes why could
this be important well if you're
targeting a part of the plant that has
those thin wispy trichomes on the bottom
of this slide those are not going to
produce cannabinoids or potentially the
useful therapeutic compounds that you're
hoping to extract like THC and CBD up
above those the first three image is
from the the top those are the glandular
trichomes and they're located on the
fruiting bodies of the plant you're not
going to find these trichomes on the
stalk of the plant and this is important
because your extraction efficiency is
going to depend on what part of the
plant you're targeting and this is from
a book chapter published by ethan russo
and myself last year entitled cannabis
pharmacology the usual suspects and a
few promising leads happy to share the
article if you guys want to send me an
email but starting with our cannabis
plant on the left if we were just to
start to break off the fan leaves and
the stems and the roots we'd find a
little to no cannabinoids or terpenes
that are very
very very small percentage and probably
it'll might be considered contamination
where the flowering tops of the cannabis
are dripping oil moving to the right if
we look at the unfertilized flower the
female plant we can find up to 30
percent by weight you know cannabinoids
and terpenoids flower tops like for
example in some broken you hemp or parts
of the producing seeds the oil
production is going to drop drastically
down you know up to 13 percent maximum
now if you're just targeting the
trichome say with mechanical separation
or something like that you can get up to
60% cannabinoid by weight in in upwards
of 8 percent of the essential oil seeds
and sprouts do not make terpenes or
cannabinoids they are a great source of
essential fatty acids in can of flavin
as well but again seeds stocks roots
these are not real sources of
cannabinoids so I'm a little bit back to
the basics as we move through this
talking about chromatography so there's
a couple different things we can use to
separate out compounds that analyze them
and they're not all created equal they
have their pluses and minuses and I'd
like to just talk about some basics of
that so we have thin layer
chromatography which is useful for
characterizing cannabis in its major
cannabinoids it has its uses in
qualitative measurements not ideal to
give you precise numbers in in most
cases but it's great at looking at is
our products decarboxylated has it
degraded it can give you some nice yes
or no answers HPLC high performance
liquid chromatography is great it's my
preferred method for looking at final
cannabinoids in cannabis there is gas
chromatography but there is a
dramatisation step required and that can
limit its usefulness and there also are
a variety of other limit tests that can
be used so what is chromatography well
it's a technique for separating complex
mixtures into their components for
example you've a mixture of jellybeans
we had a magic chromatography machine
for jellybeans
two could separate them out into their
different components and this is
important because tog Rafi as you might
have guessed or know is not just used
for separating compounds for analysis it
also can be used to isolate and purify
different types of compounds no flash
chromatography is a really interesting
one that can be used for isolation or as
a prepper to step in chromatography
you also have super critical fluid
chromatography co2 extraction as well as
centrifugal partition chromatography
which is a way of using centrifuges to
separate compounds with chromatography
and likewise those share that same
technology is used a few are analytical
techniques the techniques used to
generate numbers and things like that
for labels and in case you didn't know
HPLC basically works by taking a complex
mixture and separating it out and if its
individual components on the right we
have an example of a flash
chromatography machine the instrument as
well as the columns and the add-ons and
ancillary pieces can make a big
difference in one in what you're what
you're determining and so to give you an
example this is an HPLC for major
cannabinoids so I mentioned ancillary
equipment in the last slide this
includes your detectors and this whistle
this will stand out in this example so
here on the Left we have standards all
the same amount of these cannabinoids
have been spiked into this sample now
you might be looking at this standards
graph on the left from the America
before my kapiolani graph saying well I
thought you put in a milligram of each
cannabinoid here why are these Peaks
difference well that has to do with your
detector these cannabinoids don't all
respond the same length to the same
length of UV light so you might get
different peaks and you have to account
for that and so when we look at the raw
plant material just because there's a
really large peak of THC acid doesn't
necessarily mean that it's the most
abundant thing in there could actually
be that there's more THC than THC acid
and so definitely when you're looking at
these
it's always important to know what sort
of things you're using because not all
detectors are being used and I think
this has caused a bit of an issue with
some people working with plants
throughout time because sometimes I'm
hunting collude and cause some other
issues and we've actually seen that a
lot of labs are doing a sort of quick
and easy HPLC method are sometimes Co
eluding Peaks and counting them as THC
so when you're choosing your detectors
it's really important to get something
to use more than one now you have a UV
detector
like I said compounds are going to
respond differently to that even related
compounds and some may not even be
visible maybe a potential contaminant
likewise with MS detector maybe it's not
visible by mass spec but you've got
there's also a map type scatter
detectors which can detect everything
they're not quantitative but using this
conceptual example they can see why you
might want to use different detectors
for different samples now there are a
lot of different types of products on
the market and we're going to go through
those products what they are how they're
extracted and then at the end I have a
rating system I've developed with
colleagues of the American Chemical
Society Ezra Prior who's a former chair
of the canvas chemistry subdivision for
raiding these systems is sort of a
subjective matter based on safety and
efficiency and cost so among the
products on the market are oils waxes
and other things called shadows so oils
typically are characterized as being low
potency or not but it basically
describes its viscosity it could be
black yellow brown or colorless I think
the sort of one that people think of as
a thick blood brackish oil on the on the
right wax is this is more of a semi
solid at room temperature this may be
sort of the least clean in terms of how
it's extracted will will show a little
bit later but this is sometimes referred
to as butter cheese crumble or ear wax
so you can see it kind of has this soft
pliable nature to it now shatter is the
common the layman's term
for this very high potency product
varies in its quality
it's been winterized often and it's
devoid of waxes many fats solids and
other substances and often has a clear
consistency as you can see in the bottom
and each of these has their own ways of
extraction or you might use multiple
methods so you could have a co2 extract
that's further processed from a waxy
substance into a shadow substance
they're the oldest and most traditional
ways of making cannabis extracts are
through mechanical separation this has
been done for thousands of years it's
gotten a slightly bit better than people
just rubbing their hands together with
some cannabis and scraping it office
it was often done in ancient times so on
the Left where you see the penny is a
picture of some traditionally made hash
and this was done through pressing you
also have other types are wet or dry
automated to making cash flow you can
use screens or sibs to collect and press
on the right we see rosin Tec which is
basically taking an extract or in this
case of flour and pressing it now this
is a very pure product but it's
incomplete extract it gives a great
profile the compounds but you're leaving
a lot behind so one of the drawbacks of
rosin Tec would be that creates a very
pure product but there's a lot of waste
leftover ethanol extraction has a few
benefits it has less of an impact
environment than other solvents ethanol
can be produced in-house methanol is
non-toxic at low levels and on the right
here you can see an image a hot plate
with it's basically an ethanol still now
ethanol extraction has been used for a
long time by botanists and other people
to make tinctures and actually the
licensed pharmaceutical known as sativex
is an ethanol preparation it starts off
as a co2 extract but is ultimately
dissolved in ethanol now drawbacks
ethanol is that it can be very expensive
to purchase there are legal
I'm producing or selling tinctures but
just using ethanol by itself will
produce an impure crude extract and it's
also a flammable gas so there's extra
precautions you may want to take now co2
extraction has a lot of benefits it's
non flammable there's less of an
environmental impact there's no trace
solvent left behind no toxic [ __ ] at
most levels and it can be made to be
selective however it can cost a lot of
money to get started typically unless
you're a pro or a savant at this
terpenes are typically lost during the
extraction of the flavor and smell
profile it's typically a dark product
and there's a fixed throughput and this
is good for modern standards because you
have to have an actual and theoretical
yield and reconcile that to help control
diversion other issues and so co2 does
have some benefits there now so co2 to
continue our discussion about co2
extraction we talked about winterization
we're not talking about you know
insulating or sealing up your home
vehicle in this case it's a deal axing
process so we talked about going from
the semi solids to those clear
substances and this is typically done in
95 percent of pure ethanol at sub-zero
temperatures waxes precipitate as you
can see with the right at the top of the
vessel and are filtered out for best
results you know this is repeated
multiple times with the centrifuge and
filter many many methods exist for this
this wasn't invented recently and a lot
of these techniques for extraction are
used in the herbal products and
botanical world and have been for a
while
butane I'm only talking about
closed-loop systems these are some
pictures of what a closed-loop system
looks like you may notice there are some
subtle differences between this and what
you might find on social media about
butane I'd like to point out that there
are no canisters that aren't connected
to a hose and we think that the benefits
really the only benefit I can think of
for butane for most is the low startup
cost but with a regulation
these also have to be in blast-proof
rooms or inappropriate leave ventilated
areas so the it's an explosive solvent
there's no shortage of bad PR images
about this the solvent can cost a lot
when you're using the right grade of
solvent and select that if 'ti can be
lost with lb attempts it also can
produce a low purity crude extract often
it'll just take everything with it off
the plant open loop or blasting I would
say just don't do this it has a negative
impact on the industry it's dangerous
for the producers it's dangerous for the
workers it's dangerous for the consumers
and is a public health issue if you want
to see a video of this we have it you
can go check it out on YouTube but again
do not and do this it is a bad idea
so some of the more traditional ways of
making cannabis are still used by the
industry today
these images are courtesy of Ethan
Rousseau so the benefits to dry sift
hash such as Keith or the low startup
cost ease of production it's a solvent
free process you're not even using water
to do these extraction the terpenes are
easily preserved
now our waxy trichomes and the leaves
are very very good at preserving what's
on the cannabis plant during its curing
process and so on the top left we see a
harvested piece of cannabis a whole
plant I believe or a couple of them down
together from Morocco and the close-up
image and on the right an example of it
being chopped up next to a pile of
chopped up tobacco that can then be run
over a screen as you see in the bottom
that stainless steel tray and it can
used to be pressed that fine powder that
you see in the plastic bag that has the
hand contaminating it probably use
gloves and practice the skeptic
techniques and then you can see that
just a picture of what the substance
looks like while it's burning it's a
very pretty pure product still as a firm
actors and this could be pressed into
the unit as well another area that is
people are interested in is distillation
it is the action of purifying liquid
through heating and cooling again you
take advantage of the chemical
properties of their boiling and vapor
points and uses separate mixtures but
again this cannot separate individual
cannabinoids more like groups of them as
you can see by the temperature as well
as different terpenes are they way
slightly different weights so they're
gonna evaporate it slightly different
temperatures are different molecular
weights now I think it's some important
to say that this is a bit of an art to
doing distillation it's here a lot of
its it's a it's a very steep learning
curve is very difficult I think for a
lot of people to master this um you know
cold water hash extraction is an
interesting method it's a little startup
Cod ease of production it's typically
what we would call a low solvent solvent
freak process it does use water which I
know is a solvent but you know you're
not using butane or ethanol or something
like that
terpenes are very well preserved in this
process and this is a series these are
bags and so ice water will be loaded in
here with probably frozen cannabis and
it would be pulled or strained through a
succession of smaller and smaller
screens now the drawback is that potency
typically doesn't exceed 50% of the
active ingredients is a low market value
it's labor intensive these bags are huge
and people have to pull them up and a
lot of other particles may be included
in there you could have a fairly good
size exclusion but contaminants are not
typically removed during this process
either so it does have team seems to
have a high failure rate for QC in the
cannabis space so to sum this up come to
the extraction comparison method there
are four typical methods we discussed
mechanical classical separation the
alcohol ethanol separation white
hydrocarbon extraction such as butane as
well as co2 extraction and we've raided
the
subjectively according to safety cost
quality environmental impact just on a1
divorced yet so mechanical separation
for example gets a four because there's
no danger of people spontaneous the cost
is very cheap but the quality is much
lower than other stuff its environmental
impact this is very low there's not a
lot of waste generated that can't be
composted or recycled so it gets it gets
a score of 81 percent alcohol might
hydrocarbons have safety issues cost
issues which and potential environmental
issues which give them lower scores co2
extraction is the medium between alcohol
I started between mechanical extraction
and light hydrocarbon extraction you
know it has a high safety rating but it
has a high cost quality the products
that initially come out are okay but
they generally require further
processing there's also less of an
environmental impact but all techniques
as we'll sort of discuss have some
product safety concerns but mechanical
and co2 are the safest for workers when
properly used so let's start to put this
all together into a stun so we've talked
about all these extraction salts but has
anyone sat down and compared them side
by side in a controlled laboratory yes
at least one group so Americans for safe
access works with the International
cannabis and cannabinoid Institute it's
their research partner and you can find
out more about this research at icc i
dot science these results run in a
patient focused certified and i strongly
i some accredited lab at the university
of chemistry and technology prague in
the laboratory of shana ash Lola so what
we did is we helped to standardize some
cannabis urbe samples some hemp flour
and we would homogenized those samples
take about five milligrams put it in
whatever the extraction process was in
this instance it was an ethanol methanol
mix shake it for thirty minutes
and filter it and then load it into our
you PLC a tandem aspect so when you look
below at the cannabinoid profile we
compare different
extraction procedures for ethanol
methanol co2 and then we used water as a
control and so as you see here in these
it's a little hard to see but if you
look at CVD acid in the first column the
green red and blue bars they're
different amounts and that means because
ethanol methanol and co2 all have their
different sort of efficiencies for
extracting compounds when we look at
some of the other cannabinoids that are
pulled out of that blue bordered box you
can see the THC THC acid CBD CBD acid
all have slightly different efficiencies
when being extracted from the same plant
material it's really interesting to see
how well
Evon all extracts THC acid um but what
about the turkeys good question that no
one asked the terpenes and this is a
slide from the students at the Czech
Republic and I have the next slide some
of these are translated English but I
thought this provided a nice sort of
snapshot of what it looks like so we
have ethanol co2 and water extraction
represented here and you notice right
away that you look for human right at
the top you know it is really well
extracted in water not so well extracted
in the green ethanol in BB co2
extraction can be pretty efficient so
it's sort of a medium it's pretty
interesting just to see that there are
differences so when we only move and we
just sort of pull out some of what I
would consider the more interesting
compounds my bias we can see like pining
is more efficiently extracted in ethanol
which is very interesting you know
pining actually has pharmacological
activity it is a bronchial dilator if
you go into the woods and breathe it in
your lungs will expand so if you have a
product that's formulated to be inhale
this could be an important component
it's also an acetylcholinesterase
inhibitor so combining this with THC
would potentially synergize some of the
alerting effects of THC similar to you
know you mind might feel like it's
racing not something ideal to say take
for sleep so pining is an important part
of your product changing from co2 to
ethanol or ethanol to co2 might
change your product and what this says
is you could start with the same
material put it through different
extraction procedures and get a
different profile for example another
one is mercy again it seems to be a more
favorable to extract it through ethanol
this complicacy Daniel income
potentially enhance the sedating
qualities so if this is not something
you want your product may be using co2
would be appropriate method assuming was
really interesting compound very very
highly loves to be extracted in co2 it
also means a really interesting compound
because it's a new compound law
enforcement is using to train insects
actually to to detect drugs so drug
sniffing dogs use a crawling derivative
and but honey bees really love awesome
mean it helps regulate their social
colonies and so a year or two ago law
enforcement published a paper
demonstrating that honey bees are really
really good at detecting aweso mean in
packages and things like that so the new
drug sniffing dog are the honey bees I
think it's might be so look out if you
go to the airport you have bees
gathering on your backpack so I see see
I also did a follow-up study to this
where we they ordered a ton of CBD oils
on the market and looked at these
products we looked at the CBD content
does it mean it's declared or
legislative limit for example is it
within 10 percent of the value for THC
sometimes for for a lot of these hemp
products has to be 0.3 percent or less
color what was interesting as most of
these companies didn't list the THC on
the product but then again it wasn't
exceeding the legislative limit there
was they were spot-on for the amount of
fatty acids in the in these 20 products
but was interesting as we saw the
benzopyrene x' and poly aromatic
hydrocarbons skyrocket and some of these
and these are like that stuff you might
think are like the char marks on a
burger
if you go to a barbecue how bad is it
before you don't really know but was
interesting as we were seeing these
forms so what this might be from we
speculate we've contacted these
companies and are working with them is
that this might be from the addition of
terpenes or from poor storage conditions
or from long storage conditions some
terpenes do break down I'm into poly
aromatic hydrocarbons so if they're
adding synthetic stuff to it for
flavoring this might be another
consideration for quality control how
are you gonna store them to prevent this
breakdown so I wanted to say a little
bit about personal protective equipment
and things for considering Footwear lab
coats glasses goggles gloves respirators
and signage all any cannabis extraction
facility should have all those
appropriate things part of my job with
Americans for safe access is going and
assessing regulatory compliance
preparing operations for regulatory
inspections I give out a lot of
citations or kappa's for not wearing
proper footwear for you know lab coats
being worn outside the lab not having
glasses or goggles available you know
some equipment is irreplaceable like
your hands so always having the proper
gloves to use if you're working with
stuff that's really cold or really hot
you want to have proper glove use
respirators is another issue you need to
be medically fit tested and have proper
procedures in place for their
maintenance these are heavy OSHA fines
that we're seeing so exposure and first
aid
think OSHA right workers could be
exposed to a lot of things having worked
in cannabis operations in the past I
have to say that some of you sometimes
you don't know what's been used on the
product and if they're working with it
and you know the product has pesticides
perhaps so maybe you're processing it in
a way or maybe it's made with solvents
and it needs to be purged or it could be
the cannabis I have a colleague who's
allergic to cannabis and she'll break
out in hives if it touches her skin so
you have to think about worker safety an
exposure to these things especially if
you're a manufacturer and you're
bringing in lots of cannabis you know
additional hel
concerns of that not all terpenes are
grass for inhalation they're not all
generally regardless see a lot of these
are synthetics and there's an
interesting condition called popcorn
lung disease that's popped up and that's
from you know chronic long-term exposure
there's also some concerns over
propylene glycol when overheated it's
used in almost all C cigarettes but when
exposed to really high temperatures for
a really long time formaldehyde
releasing bodies can be found so having
you know really finely calibrated
instruments or vaporizers is also key to
safety I'm going to talk a little bit
about pesticides again for these things
you want to choose the right instrument
for what you're looking for workers
safety and the analysis and extraction
you know you definitely want don't want
your few if you're you should treat
every product coming into your facility
like it might be contaminated you don't
want your employees touching something
that's pesticides and touching doorknobs
and radios and other stuff and spreading
it around the lab and this is from the
American herbal pharmacopoeia monograph
and this is just discussing of showing
you just said here's some pesticides
they're classification and some
instrumentation methodology that has
been cited and used so this so here are
some things we don't really know very
well about canvas on the right you can
see a picture this is one of my
favorites it's from a facility they had
taken in product this is what the
producer had put on the label before
extraction and if you look at the
ingredients it all seems pretty fine
except when you get to the bottom and it
mentions that myclub butanol is one of
the ingredients in the material and
again it we don't know at what level
right and for just from looking at this
but it might be a good idea to think
about your workers being exposed to this
chronically and there is research on
this that you guys can look up the
factory workers who make this stuff wear
all sorts of equipment to protect them
another consideration is that this might
increase
during the extraction process so if
you're concentrating the stuff in
cannabis you might accidentally be
concentrating the bad stuff is it
transferred during smoke yes how much is
it absorbed we don't know what
pesticides are you looking for in your
state it's it's difficult because it's
hard to know the regulations vary there
is no EPA approved cannabis product
typically when we're trying to do
compliance assessments through a third
party and help these operations
typically we just go to the local
grossed or and see what they're selling
and chances are the operators nearby are
using those but there are solutions such
as integrated pest management and our
cultural science training is highly
recommended for cultivators and you
should always test your product before
and after extraction in case you
concentrated something or there's been
some contamination
that's why cleaning validation protocols
are really important and so cleaning
validation protocols testing proxy for
and after extraction could have
prevented some other issues so this is
just a study I just wanted to show that
you know there are not there are no EPA
tolerances or FDA relaunches for
pesticides on smoked crops or inhaled
crops but up to up to 70% of residues
will persist in cannabis smoke and this
is the first study really of its kind
and it was done by a licensed cannabis
laboratory in Washington State and so I
love this because it shows that the
cannabis labs are actually playing a
pivotal role and providing information
to inform policy so a distillation from
a pesticide study published by dr. Russo
in 2016 he said the you know to fully
assess the situation twenty distinct
cannabis samples were purchased 24
concentrates or extracts into cannabis
in fluorescence or
you know hold flowers from legal stores
in Washington so but don't use stores
and pass through witness chain of
evidence to a certified legal licensed
laboratory what were the results of that
study 22 of the 26 animals tested
positive for pesticides 84%
many Harvard multiple contaminants
attaining levels in terms of even
hundreds of thousands of parts per
billion so this includes 24 distinct
pesticides and we're talking about all
things that are pesticides or things
that kill bugs or even fungicides so
these could be student growth regulators
and things like this
these are attracted to cannabis like I
said because of the awesome e and a lot
of these things will kill bees and enter
into the food supply
as well so you know I think that we have
to be thinking about the environment as
we're applying these things to our
products and you know California
Washington State and Oregon allow
outdoor cultivation so one of the really
bad actors that was found in one sample
was by cholinesterase inhibitor a
carcinogen and a potentially a
reproductive toxin and this is a
carbonate insecticide in one sample is
found to be 255 times above the
allowable limit for any product whether
it be even a t-shirt or a fiber it was
found highly concentrated in one step so
to summarize that up 15 to 30 percent of
the samples at one California lab were
positive for pesticides some of them
were nasty some of them not so nasty but
if you want to look at more information
there's some resources here about those
and references to the studies we've
discussed so the last thing I'm going to
wrap up with is talking about a labeling
study we conducted and this looked at
the cabin I basically ordered over 80
CBD products online and we looked at
their content whether they were
accurately labeled and the first study
of this time was on just on THC product
so this is just saying we looked at THC
products first and what we found five
THC containing products about you know
17% were accurately labeled 23% were
under label and 60% were over labeled
with respect to THC content
once this shows is extraction and
applying and it can be tricky and the
more we know about solvents and the
processes the better and more consistent
we can be we've so we we looked at THC
products first and the second team look
at CBD products 84 of these products
oils teachers of vaporization liquids
and we basically as you can see there
was a issue with things being accurately
labeled under over so in this study you
have about a 50% chance the CVD product
ordered online would match what it says
and then the other 50% was but between
being under and over on that amount and
this is just showing you what the the
average milligram per mil of the
different components were in these
extracts were sold online so to
summarize this there's a couple
takeaways one is is that the cannabis
oil that has a therapeutic compounds in
it that we are very familiar with are
produced in site-specific trichomes on
the plant you know you're going to be
more efficient the more targeted you are
on your approach to separation
chromatography is a science that has
diverse applications in making products
and as well as in analyzing products
good extraction analysis will help
create accurate labels usually there are
some other issues with the supply chain
such as a representative sampling and
things like that but typically if you
know how to apply your extraction
methods you know how to analyze the
products appropriately you should be
able to generate accurate labeling you
know pesticides are a concern for all
workers in all parts of supply chain as
well as the consumer and so if you're a
business and you're watching this I'd
think about those additional protections
that you can do for your employees thank
you so much for your attention my name
is Joan Marku chief science officer for
Americans for safe access and director
of patient focused certification
happy to take any and all questions
related to cannabis thank you doctor
Marku for that informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
what is the difference between sativa
and indica that is a really great
question
so sativa and indica is typically used
by botanists to help distinguish what
cannabis looks like they're actually
using good evidence out there to say
sativas have these compounds on them and
and because of this chemical variety
they just describe the fan leaves are
they really narrow fan leaves like
fingers are they more thick fat family
so you have narrow leaves and broadleaf
plants and that's generally what sativa
and indica describes I'm the first
you know most I don't realize this but
there's really only one indica special
specimen ever found and ethnobotany if
you find it you get to name it that's
just how it works and so Richard
Shelties found cannabis indica growing
in the desert in Siberia all alone by
itself and that's was used to create the
taxonomic identification today
everything has been so bred together
that there is generally everything's a
hybrid and that net taxonomic
description that nomenclature has been
updated and is starting to be adopted so
sativa indica is a great way to help
track things but it's not really the
most scientific way thing to do use well
thank you for that looks like we have
time for one more question and it is are
there approved pesticides to use on
cannabis this is another great question
so because cannabis is Schedule one
federal agencies can't offer typically
guided
to approve things for pesticides are
typically approved for plants to use
within certain windows that being said
this public health issue and this
responsibility has not been neglected by
a lot of states so they have felt the
responsibility to put out an exempt list
of pesticides to be is you know things
like garlic oil or cinnamon oil still
stuff you don't want to inhale or get on
your skin but you know things that are
tolerance exempt and this I think this
is important and states are starting to
come up to this you know for example New
Jersey doesn't allow anything to be
considered a pesticide be used on the
plant for example if you want to put
water on the plant for purposes of
killing insects that's not allowed but
you can put water on the plant to water
though and so anything that's used as a
pesticide is not allowed in some states
because there is no federal guidance
other states have adopted that an exempt
a tolerance exempt list if the
pesticides are used within particular
windows and so I think when it comes to
it you want to use common sense
well maybe an uncommon sense but
typically you know you don't want to
spray pesticides or stuff on fruiting
bodies of the plant in late-stage times
of the plant because and it will
definitely be around in the final sample
I mean I think another consideration too
about pesticides if you do use cannabis
on soil that has had a heavy pesticide
or heavy remediation should remember
that cannabis is a because one of 200
species of angiosperms that is a bio
accumulator it loves to suck things out
of the soil like heavy metals and hemp
is still used to this day to help
remediate soil in places like Chernobyl
but that's just a way of pulling it out
of the soil and then it has to be
processed and disposed of later so again
when we talk about standards for
cultivating cannabis and things like
pesticides we want to be really careful
and and look to other crops that we know
and love and are you know and there's
integrative pest management approaches
to make that safe for everyone involved
thank you for that I would like to once
again thank dr. mark who for his
presentation would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 29th 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all from now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye